So a patient of blood type A can only receive blood from a individual who either
has an A antigen only, or no antigen at all. So that would be either
type A, which we don't have an option, or type O, which we do, thank goodness.
If we gave the patient type AB or B, although this top option,
AB has The possibility of an A antigen type
in it. It also carries with it B, and this
patient doesn't recognize B, and its body is going to mount
an immune response, and attack that blood. And of course,
type B by itself offers no A, right. There's just B,
so the body's going to attack that. Whereas type O,
doesn't have any antigen, and the body's not going to see
it as a foreign object, because it's not going to recognize
anything. And that way, we can successfully have the blood transfusion.